one little town decided to put a statue
back up in Johnston Rhode Island they
took a statue that had been taken down
in Providence and they moved it over to
this town and they put it back up this
was thanks to Providence former
Providence mayor Joe poino good son of
Italy who purchased the old statue and
brought it over to this nice town why is
this such a great story it's such a
great story not because we're all going
to take trips to Johnston Rhode Island
though maybe we should not because it's
not a bad thing say that the bigger
towns and the bigger cities all over the
even New York wants to take these
statues down it's not that not that
we've made it out of the woods that
they're going to keep their statues up
but it means that we can restore things